oh
[Music]
okay
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah let's go we love you joe
we love you joe let's go
so easy
[Music]
a
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
americans
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome back
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
hello
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we hmm it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
we love you joe yeah
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
uh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
hold on let's go
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
love you oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
my
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
they can be
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
soon
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i want
is
[Applause]
[Music]
sometimes
i
just want to tell you right now
[Music]
is
i got a brand new
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
happy
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
thank you so much
right now
[Music]
these islands from the ocean
stood strong for centuries
so it's fitting they were named after
men with golden halos
angels don't you just cause
[Music]
is
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
together
[Music]
[Applause]
we love you
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
i just made the world go round
please welcome the vice president-elect
of the united states of america
there's so many girls i hear you've been
running from the beautiful queen that
you can leave
[Music]
keep it going for a living
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening
good evening good evening
[Music]
good evening thank you thank you
good evening
so thank you good evening
so congressman
john lewis congressman john lewis
before his passing wrote democracy
is not a state it is an act
and what he meant was that america's
democracy is not guaranteed
it is only as strong as our willingness
to fight for it
to guard it and never take it for
granted
and protecting our democracy takes
struggle
it takes sacrifice but there is
joy in it and there is progress
because we the people have
the power to build a better future
and when our very democracy was on the
ballot
in this election with the very soul
of america at stake and the world
watching you ushered in a new day
for america
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to our campaign staff and volunteers
this extraordinary team thank you
for bringing more people than ever
before
into the democratic process
and from making this victory possible
to the poll workers and election
officials across
our country who have worked tirelessly
to make sure every vote is counted
our nation owes you a debt of gratitude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you have protected the integrity of our
democracy
and to the american people who make up
our beautiful country thank you
for turning out in record numbers to
make your voices
[Music]
heard
and i know times have been challenging
especially
the last several months the grief
sorrow and pain the worries
and the struggles but we have also
witnessed
your courage your resilience
and the generosity of your spirit
for four years you marched
and organized for equality and justice
for our lives and for our planet
and then you voted
and you delivered a clear message
you chose hope
and unity decency
science and yes truth
[Applause]
[Music]
you chose joe biden
as the next president of the united
states of america
and joe is a healer a uniter
a tested and steady hand
a person whose own experience of loss
gives him a sense of purpose that will
help us
as a nation reclaim our own
sense of purpose and a man with a big
heart
who loves with abandon it's his love
for jill who will be an incredible first
lady
[Applause]
it's his love for hunter and ashley and
his grandchildren and the entire biden
family
[Music]
and while i first knew joe as vice
president
i really got to know him as the father
who loved beau my dear friend
who we remember here today and
to my husband doug
[Applause]
and our children cole and ella and my
sister
maya and our whole family i love you all
more than i can ever express
we are so grateful to joe and jill for
welcoming our family into theirs
on this incredible journey and to the
woman most responsible for my presence
here today
my mother shyamala gopalan harris
was always in our hearts
when she came here from india at the age
of 19 she maybe
didn't quite imagine this moment but she
believed so deeply
in an america where a moment like this
is possible
and so i am thinking about her and about
the generations of women
black women
[Music]
[Applause]
asian white latina
native american women
who throughout our nation's history
have paved the way for this moment
tonight
women who fought and sacrificed so much
for equality and liberty and justice
for all including the black women who
are often
too often overlooked but so often prove
they are the backbone of our democracy
all the women who have worked to secure
and protect the right to vote for over a
century
100 years ago with the 19th amendment
55 years ago with the voting rights act
and now in 2020 with a new
generation of women in our country who
cast their ballots
and continued the fight for their
fundamental right to vote and be
heard
[Applause]
tonight i reflect on their struggle
their determination and the strength of
their vision
to see what can be unburdened
by what has been and i stand on their
shoulders
and what a testament it is to joe's
character that he had the audacity
to break one of the most substantial
barriers that exists in our country
and select a woman as his vice president
[Music]
but while i may be the first woman in
this office
i will not be the last
because every little girl watching
tonight
sees that this is a country of
possibilities
and to the children of our country
regardless of your gender our country
has sent you a clear message
dream with ambition lead
with conviction and see yourselves in a
way that others may not
simply because they've never seen it
before
but know that we will applaud you every
step of the way
and to the american people no matter who
you voted for
i will strive to be a vice president
like joe was to president obama loyal
honest and prepared waking up
every day thinking of you and your
family
because now is when the real work begins
the hard work the necessary work
the good work the essential work
to save lives and beat this epidemic to
rebuild our economy
so it works for working people to root
out systemic racism in our justice
system and society
to combat the climate crisis to unite
our country and heal the soul of our
[Music]
nation
[Music]
and the road ahead will not be easy
but america is ready and so
are joe and i
we have elected a president who
represents
the best in us a leader
the world will respect and our children
will look up to a commander-in-chief who
will respect our troops
and keep our country safe and a
president for all americans
and it is now my great honor
to introduce the president-elect
of the united states of america joe
[Applause]
[Music]
biden
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my fellow americans
and the people who brought me the dance
delawareans
i see my buddy tom senator tom carper
down there and i think
i think senator coons is there and i
think the governor's around and
is that ruthanne and that former
governor lutheran minor
[Music]
most importantly my sisters-in-law my
sister valerie
anyway
folks the people of this nation have
spoken
[Music]
they've delivered us a clear victory
a convincing victory a victory
for we the people
we've won with the most votes ever cast
from presidential ticket
in the history of the nation 74 million
[Applause]
[Music]
what i must admit is surprise me tonight
we're seeing all over this nation all
cities and all parts of the country
indeed across the world an outpouring of
joy
of hope renewed faith and tomorrow bring
a better day
[Applause]
and i'm humbled by the trust and
confidence
you've placed in me i pledge to be a
president
who seeks not to divide but unify
who doesn't see red states of blue
states only sees the united states
[Music]
and work with all my heart with the
confidence
of the whole people to win the
confidence of all of you
and for that is what america
i believe is about it's about people
and that's what our administration will
be all about
i sought this office to restore the soul
of america
to rebuild the backbone of this nation
the middle class
and to make america respected around the
world again
and to unite us here at home
it's the honor of my lifetime that so
many millions of americans have voted
for that vision
and now the work of making that vision
is real
it's a task d task of our time
folks as i said many times before
i'm jill's husband
[Applause]
and i would not be here without her love
and tireless support of jill
and my son hunter and ashley my daughter
and all our grandchildren
and their spouses and all our family
they're my heart joe's a mom a military
mom an educator
she has dedicated her life to education
but teaching isn't just what she does
it's who she is for american educators
this is a great day for you all
you're gonna have one of your own in the
white house
and jill's gonna make a great first lady
i'm so proud of her
[Music]
well i'll have the honor of serving with
the fantastic vice president
you just heard from kamala harris
it makes history as the first woman
first black woman the first woman from
south asia to set the first daughter of
an immigrant
ever elected in this country
[Music]
don't tell me it's not possible in the
united states
it's long overdue and we're reminded
tonight
of those who fought so hard for so many
years
to make this happen once again
america's bent the ark of the moral
universe more toward
justice kamala doug
like it or not your family you become an
honorary bride and there's no way out
[Music]
for all those of you volunteered and
worked the polls
in the middle of pandemic local elected
officials
you deserve a special thanks from the
entire nation
[Music]
and to my campaign team and all the
volunteers
and all who gave so much of themselves
to make this moment possible
i owe you i owe you i owe you everything
and all those who supported us
i'm proud of the campaign we built and
ran i'm proud of the coalition we put
together
the broadest and most diverse coalition
in history
democrats republicans independents
progressives moderates conservatives
young old urban suburban rural
gay straight transgender white latino
asian
native americans
i mean it especially those moments
and especially for those moments where
this campaign was at as low as them
the african-american community stood up
again for a minute
[Music]
i said at the outset i wanted to
represent this campaign to represent and
look
like america we've done that now that's
what the administration will look like
and act like for all those of you
who voted for president trump i
understand the disappointment tonight
i've lost a couple times myself but now
let's give each other a chance
it's time to put away the harsh rhetoric
lower the temperature see each other
again listen to each other again
and to make progress we have to stop
treating our opponents
as our enemies they are not our enemies
they are americans
they are americans
[Applause]
the bible tells us to everything there
is a season
a time to build a time to reap and a
time to sow
and a time to heal this is the time to
heal in america
[Music]
now this campaign is over
what is the will of the people what is
our mandate i believe it's this
americans have called upon us to marshal
the forces of decency
the forces of fairness to marshal the
forces of science
and the forces of hope in the great
battles of our time
the battle to control the virus the
battle to build prosperity
the battle to secure your family's
health care
the battle will achieve racial justice
and root out systemic racism in this
country
and the battle to save our planet by
getting climate under control
[Music]
the battle restore decency defend
democracy
and give everybody in this country a
fair shot
that's all they're asking for a fair
shot
[Music]
our work begins with getting covered
under control
we cannot repair the economy restore our
vitality
or relish life's most precious moments
hugging our grandchildren our children
our birthdays weddings
graduations all the moments that matter
most to us
until we get it under control
on monday i will name a group of leading
scientists and experts
as transition advisors to help
take the biden harris covered plan and
converted
into an action blueprint that will start
on january the 20th
2021.
that plan will be built on bedrock
science
it will be constructed out of compassion
empathy and concern
i will spare no effort none
or any commitment to turn around
this pandemic folks
i'm a proud democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
i'll work as hard for those who didn't
vote for me
as those who did
let this grim here of
demonization in america
begin to end here and now
[Applause]
refusal of democrats and republicans to
cooperate with one another
it's not some mysterious force beyond
our control it's a decision
a choice we make and if we can decide
not to cooperate
then we can decide to cooperate
and i believe that this is part of the
mandate
given to us from the american people
they want us to cooperate
in their interest and that's the choice
i'll make
and i'll call on congress democrats
republicans alike
to make that choice with me the american
story
is about slow yet steadily widening the
opportunities in america
and make no mistake too many dreams have
been deferred for too long
we must make the promise of the country
real for everybody
no matter their race their ethnicity
their faith
their identity or their disability
folks america has always been shaped by
inflection points
by moments in time we've made hard
decisions about
who we are and what we want to be
lincoln in 1860 coming to save the union
fdr in 1932 promising a beleaguered
country
a new deal jfk
in 1960 pledging a new frontier
and 12 years ago when barack obama made
history he told us
yes we can
[Applause]
well folks we stand at an inflection
point we have an opportunity to defeat
despair
to build a nation of prosperity and
purpose
we can do it i know we can i've long
talked about the battle
for the soul of america we must restore
the soul of america our nation is shaped
by the constant battle between our
better angels
and our darkest impulses and what
presidents say
in this battle matters it's time
for our better angels to prevail tonight
the whole world is watching america
and i believe at our best america is a
beacon for the globe
we will not leave we will lead not only
by the example of our power
but by the power of our example
[Music]
i have always believed many of you heard
me
say it i've always believed we can
define america
in one word possibilities
that in america everyone should be given
an opportunity to go as far as their
dreams
and god-given ability will take them you
see
i believe in the possibilities of this
country
we're always looking ahead ahead to an
americans freer and more just
head to an america that creates jobs
with dignity and respect
ahead of america that cures diseases
like cancers
and alzheimer's ahead to an america that
never
leaves anyone behind a head of america
that never
gives up never gives in
this is a great nation it's always been
a bad
bet to bet against america we're good
people this is the united states of
america
and there's never been anything never
been anything we've been able not able
to do
when we've done it together folks
in the last days of the campaign i began
thinking about a hymn
that means a lot to me and my family
particularly my deceased son beau
it captures the faith that sustains me
which i believe sustains america and a
hope
and i hope it can provide some comfort
and solace the 230
million thousand americans who've lost a
loved one to this terrible virus this
year
my heart goes out to each and every one
of you hopefully this
him gives you solace as well it goes
like this
and he will raise you up on eagle's
wings
bear you on the breath of dog and make
you just sign like the sun
and hold you in the palm of his hand
and now together on eagle's wings we
embark on the work
that god and history have called upon us
to do
with full hearts and steady hands
with faith in america in each other with
love
of country a thirst for justice let us
be the nation that we know we can be
a nation united a nation strengthened a
nation healed
the united states america ladies and
gentlemen
there's never never been anything we've
tried we've not been able to do
so remember as my grandpa our grandpappy
sam and i walked out of his home
when i was a kid up in scranton he said
joey keep the faith
and our grandmother when she was alive
she yelled no joey spread it
spread the faith god love you all may
god bless america
and may god protect our church thank you
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
spray
oh
[Music]
damn
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there is no easy way
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
folks
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
now
[Music]
you